The sociopathic types too,
they prey on the elderly,
like they're bad people.
Oh yeah.
Well this is a big problem now with the
computer.
So I mean close to my grandma,
she calls me up and out of the blue
she's like,
I just got a call from you and Mexico
saying that you were stranded there and
needed me to send you 1500 bucks.
I was like,
what the.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Well that's associated sociopath,
sociopath to do that.
Or they're just like opportunistic
people or what's the difference to be
the real psychopathic types state.
They have no conscience.
Like you're there to be plucked.
You're an MPC in a video game.
It's had been described.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
and they're relatively rare and they do
have to move around and you know,
they can be successful in
extraordinarily corrupt environments for
short periods of time,
but it's just not a stable solution.
I can give you an example.
Well,
I'm curious,
what do you think about like the high
ranking officers in the Nazi party where
these psychopaths that were thriving and
a unstable corrupt situation or these
otherwise decent people that just got
twisted up and the and while they were
there,
a little of column a and a little of
column b,
you know,
like there was certainly openings in the
Nazi hierarchy's for people who were
compassionless and cruel and vengeful
and,
and all of that.
The SS is a good example of that.
But there's a great book that I would
recommend to your,
to your listeners,
to your viewers called ordinary men,
uh,
by Christopher Browning.
And so it's a great book and it tracks
the development of.
So when the Nazis moved through Poland,
they left policeman behind to maintain
order,
let's say,
but it was still under wartime and
Browning track the behavior of this one
unit of policemen.
They were all middle aged guys.
Just typical middleclass [inaudible]
guys.
They'd grown up really before Hitler.
So they weren't thoroughly indoctrinated
like the Nazi youth say.
And uh,
and they were sent to Poland and their
commander said,
look,
you guys,
it's war time and you know,
there are traders everywhere and you're
going to have to do some pretty horrible
things here,
but if you don't have to,
you can go home if,
if you think that's just too much.
And none of them did and you think,
well why not?
They had the opportunity,
but the reason was,
well they were comrades,
let's say in arms,
you know,
so they had that spree decor thing going
and they were all thinking,
well I'm not gonna like run away and
leave my colleagues to do all the dirty
work.
It's a war and duty to have a duty.
Yeah,
okay.
So fine.
So you know,
they started by rounding up all the Jews
who were between 18 and 65,
the man and shipping them away.
And they ended up by,
this is,
this is rough,
it's a rough book.
They ended up taking naked pregnant
women out into the middle of fields and
shooting them in the back of the head.
And so you think,
well,
how does a man transform in that manner
and Browning shows you like,
it's not pleasant.
They went psychological hell each step
of the way.
But they went,
you know,
so lots of times it was ordinary men who
went down the bad path one step at a
time and sometimes it was like people
who were rotten to the core,
like the minister of propaganda or
Magali the doctor.
I mean,
you know,
he was a sadistic psychopaths of the
highest order
is um,
is there a mastermind at,
it seems so complicated to,
to,
to transform an ordinary man as the book
says,
and to just someone who's willing to,
to execute a pregnant,
innocent woman.
Is there a mastermind that plots the
course of that?
Or is it just,
I'm circle like,
it just happened naturally as the,
along with the objectives of the like
how did,
how do they orchestrate something so
complicated?
Well,
I mean the,
the Germans were an organized,
are organized people were an organized
people and Hitler really didn't give out
directives precisely.
He sort of hinted at what he might want.
And then his minions would get together
and you know,
lay out policies in accordance with what
they thought were his wishes.
And I mean there's a book,
another book I would recommend called
Eichmann in Jerusalem.
And Eichmann was really the architect of
the final solution in many ways and it's
a character or logical analysis of
Eichmann and Eichmann was in no way a
psychopath,
you know,
he was perfectly capable of,
I think,
I think this is actually a true story.
I might have it confused with another
story,
but it doesn't matter really.
It's,
it's,
it's the same idea he won.
There's a story about him driving home
after work one day and running over a
cat and having like a terrible emotional
reaction to it,
you know,
and it's not like his kids didn't love
them and you know,
but,
and he wasn't out there actually killing
people.
He was just making the plans.
He was the bureaucrats behind the scenes
and he was the sort of guy who had his
mum do his laundry when he went off to
the army,
you know,
he was a.
He was a faceless bureaucrat and he
would have worked in any bureaucracy.
He was worried about his next promotion.
He wasn't thinking about the larger
consequences and so,
and that's Hannah Arendt and she.
That's a very classic book,
a Eichmann in Jerusalem and that's,
that's very much worth reading if you're
interested in this sort of thing.
One of the interesting things I always
heard about the Nazis that really
humanizes them in a way is that they
were,
and you could,
I might be wrong about this,
but they were passing out alcohol to all
the soldiers,
especially those in the concentration
camps to keep them intoxicated all the
time so that they could not confront the
horrible things they were doing.
Yeah.
Well,
they had all sorts of,
of,
of les learned how to do it across time.
Right.
I mean,
you know,
it,
it.
So Hitler started.
One of the things Hitler started.
It's a very strange story in many ways
because Hitler was obsessed with order
and cleanliness.
He was a very orderly person and he was
very sensitive to discussed,
you know,
because you think,
well,
the Nazis were afraid of the Jews,
you know,
because they were out there and that's
not right.
What's more accurate is that the.
Especially Hitler,
he,
uh,
he was,
he was very sensitive to discuss.
That's what it looks like.
And if you're disgusted by something
then you want to eradicate it.
Right.
If you're afraid of something,
you want to run away from it.
If you're disgusted by it,
you want to burn it to the damn ground.
You want to get rid of it.
And his writings,
I read a book called Hitler's table
talk,
which was his spontaneous discussions
during dinner time from 1939 to 1942.
It's really another amazing book.
And we had been doing some work and
inspired a bit by Jonathan Heit,
who's done a lot of work on disgust and
the relationship between trait
personality and I was reading this book
at the same time and it was just
unbelievable how often Hitler referred
to the people he was eradicating the
Slavs and the Gypsies and the Jews and
all the people he went after as
parasites and as rats and insects and
all of that.
So they were kind of put into that
category.
So,
and here's the horrifying part of that
story.
Like when Hitler came to power,
he put it in a lot of public health
initiatives,
um,
including master book,
tuberculosis screening,
which actually turned out to be a good
thing.
And at the same time he went on a
beautify the factories campaign.
And so he convinced the German,
uh,
factory owners and so forth to,
to increase the levels of hygiene in the
factories to get rid of the rats and the
mice to plant flowers out front,
you know,
to make everything look neat and
orderly.
And the insecticide they used was Zike
lawn.
Well,
as icon to,
so to eradicate the routes and the
insects cycle on slightly different
formulation was the gas that was used in
the concentration camps.
And so Hitler went from cleaning up the
rats and the mice in the factories and
the insects and then he went into the
mental hospitals and started cleaning up
in there and then like,
it just went broader and broader again,
sort of one step at a time,
you know,
when the Germans had plenty of reason to
be resentful and hateful because I mean,
think about what they went through.
We can't even imagine it the first of
all,
there was world war one.
And so there was many men like Hitler
himself who served in the trenches.
And there's one story about Hitler.
He,
um,
he won a medal for heroism in World War
One and he was sitting around with a
group of his buddies and went off to do
something.
God only knows what,
when he came back they were all dead
because,
uh,
a mine and not a mine,
I don't remember what's kind of some
kind of shell Atlanta did middler and
killed them all.
So like that changes you,
you know,
and then afterwards there was all these
brutalized men who'd come out of the
trenches.
I mean,
you just can't imagine what it must've
been like in the trenches,
you know,
especially if you're there for like a
couple of years,
you aren't the same person get out of
there,
you're unemployed,
your countries in ruins.
Then the hyperinflation hits and every
single person in Germany who ever saved
any money at all is flat,
bloody broke.
And then there's a communist revolution
brewing in Russia and it's like it's
hell.
And the Nazis came along and said,
well,
not only are we going to restore order
in greatness,
but we're going to bloody well tell you
whose fault this is.
It's like,
and Hitler,
I've studied him a lot trying to
understand what happened.
And Hitler was Carl Jung called them the
mouthpiece of the collective unconscious
of the German people.
So imagine there's all this resentment
and hatred brewing underneath the
surface and all of this chaos is there
and the desire for order is like
clamoring and everyone's minds and
Hitler comes along and he's,
he's a very powerful emotional oratory
and he's watching the crowd and he
listened and when he says thing a,
nothing happens.
When he says thing B,
everybody roars.
And so he takes note of that and it's
not even conscious exactly right because
he's being molded by the crowd and so
they roar and so we think so that's a
reinforcement.
That's a reward.
And so then he goes down that line a
little bit farther and they roar some
more and then he tries something else
and it's silent what they want.
You Bet exactly that man.
He,
he acts out the dark desire of the mob.
So he becomes the embodiment of the dark
desire of the mob.
And that's partly,
that's partly why he had the charisma.
It's right because there's this
unconscious fantasy brewing in the back
of everyone's minds.
You see that to some degree now with
Antifa for example,
and their proclivity towards violence.
You know what you asked what?
Just exactly what's going on there.
Well,
hip there came to embody the desire of
the German people for order and revenge
and he,
he embodied that fully know.
And you could say,
so what happened was a collaboration
between him and the people.
It wasn't Hitler turned everyone into
Nazis.
It's like,
no,
that's not how it works.
I'm sure there was a lot of good people
still left over who got just overrun by
the mania to well were disgusted.
Well,
the other,
the other thing too is that,
you know,
people are not that brave in everybody
thinks this is one of the things I teach
in my maps of meaning class,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
you,
you look at Nazi Germany in the thirties
and you think,
well I'd be one of the heroes who
rescued the Jews.
It's like statistically that's very
improbable.
Right?
And one of the things I've learned in
the last year with all this strange
political,
what would you say,
this strange situation that I've been in
is how unlikely it is for people to
speak up.
They just won't even tenured professors
who are tenured,
they're protected.
It's like the probability they'll,
they'll pop their head up and say
something that might make them
identifiable is very,
very low.
So scary.
Yeah,
I guess you're right.
Well,
at that time,
and you know Nazi Germany,
the stakes were as high as it could get.
They didn't tolerate.
That's right.
That's exactly right.
But even when the stakes are low,
people won't speak up.